Gigi Levy Weiss, thank you so much for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
It's so great to have you.
Thanks for having me.
Where are you calling from? From Israel right now?
I'm in Israel. In this small place called Rishpon which is just outside of Tel Aviv.
Next to the beach. Yup, can't complain.
Wonderful. Wonderful. Amazing. So, you know.
Gigi, you're one of the most prominent investors in Israel.
And I'm gonna allow myself not to be humbled at this point. You can be humble later on.
But you know, from amazing time as CEO of 888 Holdings to an incredible angel investor,
family man, Board of Directors of some incredible non-profits that are doing some really
noteworthy work in Israel and abroad. I'd love to spend these 20 minutes just to you know,
peek to your brain on, who are you? and how do you find these incredible opportunities?
How do you go about investing in a seed stage company, in people?
Rather than you know, just look in matrix and ideas. Can you just give me a little bit start about
What's your biggest passion and what really motivates you?
Wow. So I'd say at the end of the day I think that what I really enjoyed doing is working with amazing people.
I'm a people's person and not working with people is difficult for me and so, whatever I do,
when I founded companies, when I was a CEO, when I was in the military. It was always in roles that
I could surround myself with amazing people. And I think that when I left my last CEO position
which was nine or ten years ago, and I started thinking what I wanna do with the rest of my time.
And I was just to take another CEO position but what occur to me is that what I really like about
being the CEO was working with people, on product, on strategy, on solving issues.
What I really didn't like is working on how many vacation days people are getting.
And who's getting a salary raise or not. And you know, doing all these other things including investor relations
Because the last job was a public company. And I'd really didn't like that. And so, I said,
"Maybe I can find a job that has only the things that I like. Without the things I don't like."
And basically, investing in early stage start up does that. it is the perfect combination for me because I
spend as long as the founders want me to. I spend time with them on everything that I love.
And everywhere where I can bring value. And you know, thank God I'm still close to being operational enough
to be able to bring some value. But I don't deal with everyday company management.
I love that. So you're a very active investor. You form a partnership with your founders.
And you enjoy you working in with them beyond just the noticeable check size that you're providing them.
So, I think that I've invested over the years. As an angel, I've invested in more than 120 companies over many years.
Over 16 years now. I started when I was still having a day job. And this was a hobby, like everybody else’s.
And so, 120 companies. And then we had an accelerator for a period of time so that was another 80.
And then in the fund, we invested in more than 40. And so, I've touched many entrepreneurs.
And I think that my biggest pride is that I think all of them other than really a handful
are people that I would invest in again, are people that I enjoyed working with.
And are people that are really amazing individuals that ended up being also friends.
And so you know, one of the biggest difference in, we're a fund that being set up by three founders
Pete, James, and me, and I think one of the biggest difference is between us and other funds
you know there are also other great funds, one of the biggest differences is that
we remember what being the founder is like and you'd never hear us say things like, "My company."
When I talk about a company where I invested in you know. We don't think that by giving the company money
became our company. We are lucky to be able to join the journey of entrepreneurs
and help as much as we can hopefully.
But that doesn't make it our company. And that doesn't make it in any way, that doesn't give us the right to think
that because we gave money, we called the shots. It is the founders’ company. The founders are in the trenches.
They are the ones not sleeping at night. They’res the one working 24 hours a day.
We're just joining the ride and trying to help as much as we can. And so yes,
we have a very deep partnership with the founders. Many times, the people ask me, "Do you insist to be on the Board?"
And I say, "Look I don't insist being on the Board but I do insist on being the last meeting before the Board."
Meaning, I want to be that person that is on the side of the founders. Close to the founders.
So that before they decide how they present things, they come to me and say, "What do you think?"
And that's the kind of relationship we have with the founders we invest in.
And just to give you a bit of context. On another interview I saw that you mention
that you're seeing about 2000 deals a year. Out of those you have invested in specific year in about seven
So, you really do pick the founders that you get to work with.
And it's not just writing a check to any nice person that comes by the door but it's more than that.
I think you also mentioned something along the lines of, "When we look an opportunity,
we look at 70% on the people, 20% of the field, and 10% into the idea." Talk to me about that.
What does that mean 70% of the people?
So, the first thing I think that what people need to understand is that the earlier we invest in more waits we give to the people
Right. If you're investing in a growth round where the company is already making $15 million revenues,
and you can see the churn, and you can see exactly then at the end of the day
clearly, you're also wanna be in love with the founding team and the management team.
But in a way, a company that sells $15 million maybe there's another CEO also that can do the job
If the founder decides to leave or something. So, you're basically putting a lot of focus on the product
on the numbers, on what's really working and not working. And then there's of course, that's to the people.
or less to the people. If you go precede, all the way to the beginning. When you invest on to a bunch of people,
Sometimes one or two people with the deck. Sometimes there's not even a deck.
Sometimes the deck is horrible. When you invest in them, then most of the weight you're putting is on the people.
And when I try to quantify it I look back so I would ask these question first time, I think six or seven years ago
And so, I said, "Could I try to create an algorithm that basically tells me what to do and I'll get back to this in the second.
Because we have created this." And I try to understand what was my guiding line and so, the reality is that
I say it's 70% to the people because that's the most important thing. It's a 20% to the field and 10% to the idea.
However, there's a bunch of disclaimers around it. The first disclaimer is that there are field that I don't invest in.
And so why it's only 20%? It's binary so you know. Yes. The field impacts, if it's one of the fields I invest in
I give 20%. But if it's for example semiconductors that we don't invest in, then clearly that's binary.
Yup. Similarly, with the idea. The idea is if it's the right team and the right field, I really don't care about the idea too much.
Because that's gonna change a in time. However, if the idea is really bad,
that's gonna impact my analysis of the team, right?
If they came with a really really bad idea then it impacts. So, it is really a bit more balance but in reality is that
most of our decision making ideally state is a lot around the team.
Okay. So, Gigi, between us and between the couple of thousand others that are gonna watch this,
Out of the 120 angel investments plus 40 with the fund, how many do you feel that you had a personal impact
on the journey of the founder? A positive impact. An honest question.
Yeah. So, I think that clearly, I need to be careful here because my explanation to myself of the hard work that I'm putting in
has gotta be conditioned on me believing that I'm making an impact.
And so, clearly, I'm biased and I think that I made tremendous impact on everybody.
But realistically, I think that in every company that I've invested in there is being a bunch of points where
clearly, they could have gotten maybe the same device from somebody else smarter than me.
But i think there were a couple of points where me being there at the right time with the right answer.
Save them time. Or save them money. Or got them to the right place. Now, there are areas where their companies were
we saw the company first $700 million. I brought the buyer. I negotiated the deal.
I closed the deal. And so that's very tangible.
But I think that actually, the most important ones are the ones where that are not around.
You know, me being involve with big success. It's me being involve in the tough times.
Late night calls. Exactly, you know. Somebody leaving and everybody's broken. Or the product's not working.
And you need to reiterate again and again and again. And you need somebody to look you in the eyes
and tell you that this is what’s happening to everybody. And that's okay and you shouldn't break.
Or these times where somebody is coming to you and you just don't wanna continue doing what he's doing
because it's so tiring and so difficult and you give them an honest analysis of why they should or why they shouldn’t.
I think that you know, one of the things I'm most proud of is that I think that every once in a while
I ran into somebody that comes to me and tell me, "Do you know you saved me for years of my life.
And I owe you for that, a lot more than I owe the people that they told me to continue."
Because sometimes you know, from where you sit you see things differently.
And you know that some thing's not gonna work. Or you know that something is in the wrong direction.
Or you know competition, or you know which way ahead in a way that's gonna be tough to catch up.
So, you are just telling me about the time you find founders are much more appreciative when you actually
when they confide in you their worries and you actually are there for them and you give them some advice
that could actually save them some dreadful years.
Yeah. I think that at the end of the day a lot the advice that I give people is not necessarily on huge things.
What I found over the years is that, yes of course every once in a while, there's a big strategy session
and I can help in that and that's great. But the reality is that a lot of it is on the small things
And so, if our founder decides that he needs to let go of somebody and he's never done that before
He's never let go of anybody in the United States, or he's never done this or that.
And these things, you can either not spend a month in understanding how to do it
or you can ask somebody in your place who did it before or you need to sign an agreement with an affiliate.
You've never done that before. You don't know what to do. And so, these are the kind of things
that I think many times, the relationship are kind of very practically it could be, "What's ups?" in the middle of the night.
I'm gonna ask you Gigi. Do you have two minutes?
Is it WhatsApp message? Or is it a weekly meeting? A phone call? Email?
So, I think that it's a combination. It's all of the above and it's a combination.
And the reality is that usually with most companies I have a weekly call or sometimes if the frequency does not require that
Maybe every two weeks. But then there would be emails. And there would be WhatsApp’s,
and there would be messengers and messages and so on. And everybody was kind of pinned me at the right moment
and I try to keep time in my calendar to basically get back to everybody.
Because the point is that a lot of these advice is very timely and so if you can't give the answer now
then the answer is not that valuable. Because the founder already had to go to others
and asked questions and consult the lawyers and so on.
And also, if you need to make a product decision you know. If they want to ask you something about new design,
you can't give them the answer in three days. The sprints already over.
Okay Gigi. Hold on. You're invested in over a hundred companies. You're still running a fund.
And you're actively looking at thousands of opportunities per year. How do you make time to answer people?
Literally, how tangibly do you make the time to go and answer WhatsApp?
So first of all, I think that I work more than I ever thought I'm gonna work as an investor, that's a reality.
For all of you out there, the thing that investor life is kind of going to the beach every day.
You may have the option to go to the beach every day because theoretically nobody tells you what to do.
But actually, that does not happen. And it will take them about five years to realize that you haven't done much. Yeah
Exactly. So, i work more than I ever did. That's one thing.
The second thing is that I'm a very very very efficient and effective time manager.
My days are very very tight. I work at very high energy throughout the day and many of the nights sadly.
And that's that. And I think that.
I'll tell you a story. Many years ago, when I started my first company, actually my second company,
And I was after being an air force pilot and I was used to this ecosystem where basically people respond to each, you know.
You have a question. You asked somebody and they answer.
And I remember trying to sell my product many years ago and I would send emails to people and they would not reply.
And I would beg then if they could still put a bit a job I could into the email that allowed you to know the defects.
You open it and read it. And so, I would see that they're reading the email and not answering and I'm like,
What's happening here? Couldn't you just click reply and say "No."
Or if you want to be nasty, click reply and say "Never write me again."
But something and nothing. And I took a commitment that it doesn't matter who I am and how successful I am
That's never gonna happen to people writing me. So, everybody writing me always gets a reply.
I try to make it very fast. Some kind of a inbox zero person but it's difficult sometimes.
And that's a commitment that takes a lot of my time. But it's also a lot of energy that I give back into the ecosystem
Or I try to give back. And also, I mean let's be frank. Every company that asked me a question or
every new business plan that I look at a deck, it's not just for the benefit of those I'm replying to
I'm also learning from it. Right. So every day I read, I look at the deck and I say, "Wow, that's interesting."
I didn't know that this business is so large. I didn't know that these are competitors in this field.
I didn't know that there's a new way to do something. And so, I'm trying to learn from everything.
And so, yeah, it's a lot of work.
Do you have a systematic approach of how you appreciate the deal flow that you have?
So, let’s say you have a few hundred deals per month. Is there a certain way which you approach these deals?
Or is it okay based on the industry, based on the way the founders are communicating with you?
You mean how do I evaluate? How do you judge a deal? How do I evaluate?
So, there's basically two things. The first thing is that for years now is that what I'm doing is I'm reading everything.
And then I started what i call the email ping pong which is base at playing email table tennis with founders asking questions.
These questions basically they save me time from having meetings.
But they also allow me to see how could the founders
deal with questions. Deal with hard questions.
Are these binary questions like will they make it to the next round for a meeting or not?
None of them are questions that you know, there's no chi chi that people are sending around
"Gigi's asking you these questions." But I am looking at a single key that you know, it's could be around competition,
Could be around product, could be around team, could be around anything else.
And basically, what I'm seeing is not just what they say, but also how they say it, and how fast they say it.
And how do they take criticism. And how do they take that out. And how do they take the harder questions
that indicate that I maybe not as impressive as they would like me to be.
And you'd be shocked how much you can find out from these things. And so you know.
And if somebody, I mean let's face reality. If somebody sends me a deck and I send him a few questions
and it takes him four or five days to get back to me and he doesn't have a good answer.
Like you know, "Sorry I was in military service or something." then I mean, if it takes four or five days to get back to me
How long would it take him to get back to customer? How long would it take him to get back to a candidate?
How long would it take him to get back to an investor? Another investor.
Right, right. Not just on the seed round. But you're also thinking about the future rounds.
And how can you get more partners on board. Exactly. So, I learned from that.
And so, for like from every 10 companies that I get,
there would be probably four or five that are either in field that I totally don't invest in
Or competing with something that I'm already investing in. So, let's say that half of them I can disqualify very quickly.
Then there's gonna be around another three that will be disqualified in the ping-pong.
Once I understand the business better and I see. And then for every ten, there's two that I end up meeting.
Okay. And being that I'm getting around almost 10 every day, every work day.
Then that ends up being about 30 or 40 meetings a month. That's usually end up being less than one investment a month.
So, it's a pretty crazy flow.
That's pretty pretty crazy. Gigi, do you know just a minute or, 'cause we're almost out of time and I'm so sad about it
Talk to me about covid-19. We're almost, it looks like we're starting to see the light again at the tunnel.
By the time this interview is published, hopefully it's much much better than it already it is right now
Fast track and effects, you did something that's very contrariant
to a lot of other founders around the world. Talk to me about that.
So, I think that we started seeing that with covid everybody was kinda retracting and not investing anymore or investing less.
And clearly, by the way the best teams and the best CEOs continued raising money. That's good.
But everybody else it also needs to raise money and grow.
And we looked at it and we said that, it's either that we, like everybody else gonna say, "We’ll wait and see."
Or we try to challenge the industry and actually do what we think is the right thing
Which is actually to invest more in seed at this stage. Why?
Because seed companies are basically company that are gonna work now for a few months on their product.
They're not dependent on the current recession or non-recession.
It's the best time to be heads on and working on your product.
And basically, the innovation economy does not need to stop. It is the future and we need to continue fueling it.
And you know we have money. We're given money barrel piece to invest it and not to sit on it.
And so we said let's do something which is exactly the opposite.
So, when everybody else were saying, “We’re slowing down.”, we said, "We're accelerating."
What did we do? We took all the capabilities that we had before which are product that we built
like the company brief which allows us to get structured data.
It allows everybody to send data about their company to investors. Wonderful.
And so we told everybody, "If you're submitting a company brief to us and you're looking at the investment docs we put out,
because we don't want any negotiations on the documentaries, or standard safe documents
They're completely standard and you can read them beforehand.
And you know exactly what's gonna be the evaluation. You know exactly what's gonna be the standards we're taking.
So that depending on your stages, it's always 15% for one million or one and a half million or two million
then we promise initial feedback in three days. And a decision in nine days.
Wow. And we're not saying exactly how much we got but I can tell you that it's in the thousands.
Wow. And I can tell you that basically we are likely to have built a very robust system.
Technological system that basically helps us digest everything.
And so, every deal that comes in, it's being ranked by our algorithms.
It doesn't mean that, we never say no without a human watching it. So, you know this is not an automated business.
This is a decision support system more than anything else. However, we're clearly riping right now.
We're enjoying the fruits of the hard work we've done over the last few years.
Because every company that comes in now, I know exactly what to look at.
I know exactly what are the things that need to pay attention to.
And then that also allows us to write more details in rejection emails to those that we reject.
Or to ask the right questions to the one we wanna continue with. And so far, we made a new investments and we love it.
Wow. So, Gigi, once an entrepreneur, always an entrepreneur. That obviously comes across.
And you know, I had so many things I wanted talk about about your experiences in air force pilot
and comparing that some other things that you experienced as a founders, an investor.
And a bit about who you are as a person. And the things that really really make you passionate.
But one thing that I have to say that I'm hugely inspired by is the high energy.
And that something I'm trying to practice myself.
I'm trying to learn how can I bring the highest energy to my work ethic.
And to the meetings that I hold. And to reallly maximize the time that I'm working with people.
And providing value. And knowing to put myself away from the position where I don't add value.
Which is I think often one of the hardest things to do.
You know, at the end of the day, a lot of this is being truthful to yourself you know.
What many people do is that they take something up on themselves or they’re in the meeting or something
and they're not giving everything. You know they're reading emails, they're thinking about something else.
Which is fine. Everybody has these moments. However, if you wanna be truthful to yourself,
then when you are in something, you need to be 100% in it.
I love it. And if you can't be 100% in it, then you're probably in the wrong place.
Then find a better place for yourself.
Gigi, I love it. I know you're so busy and I have to let you go. But very last question.
I need three words that best describe you.
Yeah, so you know. I think that at the end of the day, a more interesting exercise is like a sentence
Just like the three words. But if I, you gave me 20 minutes heads up that I need to come up with this so.
Not nearly enough.
But I think that if I, this is something that I've been thinking a lot about myself, about my life, about being a parent
about my kids. And you know, the three values at the end of the day that I think that if I had to choose
what would be the one that I would love to use to define myself,
the three are Love, Passion, and Care.
These are the three. And I think that you know, all three of them, in the way do not sound like business-related ones.
But they are the core of every business success. It's love, passion, and care.
And I think that if I had the chance to add a couple more,
one of them would be Learning, and the other one would be Speak.
Right. Which are more kind of concrete to the business world.
But love, passion, and care the ones that I think, would love to think are defining me.
Gigi, thank you so so much for the inspiration. Thank for having me. Thank you for the friendship
And take care. This was wonderful. Thank you.
Great. Bye Bye.